what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here John we have made it to the end of
the Cobra Kai says an one I know it's
only taking us a few months to watch a
series of people watching a week or much
less than before we go into this I got
to give a heads up Casey you haven't
been around for any other ones we can
only do a 10-minute reaction for this
we're gonna watch the whole thing we got
to cut it up into ten minutes YouTube
rules not ours and sometimes that
doesn't even work what we're gonna give
it a shot today yeah we do full-length
TV show reactions over at our patreon as
well as weekly Q&A s and music video
coverage and over there I cover the show
attack on Titan just made the season two
did season four the flash I starting
Gotham John covers Riverdale he's on
season two did most of Atlanta Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood he started
up and as well as channel zero saturday
morning cartoons such as Steven universe
in Adventure Time he also does and
together we cover my hero academia of
course wrapping up Cobra Kai and then
we're got to finish Black Lightning and
then we're gonna add a new one to the
roster we're thinking supernatural so
you go check us over at patreon
appreciate the support very much Danny
and Ronnie are gonna fight right yeah no
no Danny's gonna fight again
[Laughter]
whoa
but nothing y'all for a second was gonna
be the only one whoa we go bring about
no now the new uniforms the ones in the
thumbnail
it's been enough time yeah yeah
the roar dude kid I feel like there's
gonna be a swim to like moment but
Johnny's gonna not gonna let him take it
yes popcorn movie time did it here got a
black belt black belt is like no time at
all there it is there's the move boom
dirty Danny Larusso Tim that can't be
real
don't they always make a big deal about
that being an illegal move in movies and
shows you there's oh it's way more
context
ooh whoa not bad
yeah they wear no protective gear yeah
seriously
oh hawk don't let your don't let your do
get
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm gonna kick some serious ass
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna be better than your dad for
you next
[Music]
[Applause]
sportsman like conduct going on in this
do not blow robbie before the fight okay
I say you got a drop kicked in the
stomach out they're gonna fight each
other please join me as we strive to end
intolerance in our time students really
taken over the turn [ __ ] in the face
yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
like are these guys you clearly have a
years more experience or having a hard
time gets his kid who's spent a few
months training big boy
hey man I saw Miguel has done
whoa tossing the flip dude this is
Miguel actors like really committed
[Music]
feral dog whoa who does these invites
[Music]
you don't remember your first tournament
being like a tech administer notice all
the people who are like flippin suck
spend a little less time flipping a
little more time punching and kicking
his stuff well obviously Hawks gonna
lose yeah
this looks more like accuracy you just
not like watching his kid get hurt
who's he gonna he's yeah he's probably
gonna call out at some point when he
gets a particularly good thanks dad
other dad so awkward yeah flashback to a
third person point of view this is the
best damn predicted he's a new brother
whoa dragon the Bruce Lee story there's
this surrogate father
no do those anger problems
Miguel that I did not expect for him to
get so dark I go out there and kick some
ass use that shoulder a lot yeah man
he's like the one famous karate guy
gonna lose oh my god the fight of the
century yeah oh damn gal doesn't know
who to rewind it by rage man oh oh dude
I want Miguel the way honestly I mean
despite all this look yes the one Miguel
away he's what I've been most invested
[Music]
oh dude I was gonna get [ __ ] bad-ass
shot I just feel at heart he's gonna be
like even better with just me to hit
he's gonna do the whole neo thing or
it's
[Music]
oh damn I had a way to be the bigger man
oh wow
[Music]
one more sake sweep the leg moments
flashing back winning since a dude
season two is all gonna be about again
Johnny reorganising is teaching no I
think season two is gonna have a fallout
with Miguel and Johnny in the beginning
oh that's me
[Applause]
[Music]
Miguel's the winner but look who he's
become yeah this is really fascinating
yeah he does not like this and they
should notice how to throw their
unexpected turns once in a while that's
really fast
yeah this shows a buildup
it's like breaking bad yeah we're only
gonna go five seasons we know exactly
[Music]
why on wax off am i right
school doesn't have no time to run the
car dealership I'm gonna know you want
no Cobra Kai is back where it belongs
back on top
everyone close the book on us please
show us if the real stories only just
begun X time oh god no fascinating
fascinating stuff a lot of a lot of a
finale we gasp and subscribe to reject
nation and check us out patriot let's
took a lot of unexpected turns a lot of
unexpected events here I don't know how
I feel about I forget the character's
name the original Cobra Kai instructor
showing up at the end it just brings it
into this whole other life
cheesy serious territory to me yeah I
mean he does come in like a super
villain yeah all that back lighting a
mini steps yeah it's like
quintessentially villainous having been
around a lot of I don't know the karate
world but the Taekwondo world and
knowing Taekwondo instructors and all
those things it's not like a kung fu
movie it's [ __ ] it's the valley it's
in the valley this is not because that's
what kind of made the first half of this
show actually the whole season really
interesting because you know Jonny
Lauren's starting up a karate school
it's kind of silly this childhood
rivalry of how much karate mented these
two dudes Johnny and Danny when they
were kids it's like this real personal
thing but it's not this like bigger
world I don't know how to put it I know
the movies get bigger part of the fun of
it was grounded in the reality of what
la is like of what the valley is like
but you got these two dudes who have
this like childhood love for karate
/ but now this is bringing it into that
territory of is this gonna get serious
and bigger Napoli yeah yeah imagine
there's plenty of room for them to
continue with the pallet they've got up
here plus - I mean like every season
gets a bit more intense as it reaches
its finale and every time I come into
one of these thinking it's gonna pick up
super dick it never quite does but yeah
I mean I did think that was a pretty
sinister final note yeah which is an odd
shade I guess for Cobra Kai for me they
like to go full-on sinister but I mean I
love the array of conflicting emotions
they brought up throughout this episode
and the way that like I think it's cool
when a show can do that where it's like
we can see most all the details and
we're like there's so many ways for you
guys to put these differences aside and
just make things okay again and there
are so many understandable ways in which
that is not gonna happen anytime soon
you know and this episode was really
exemplary of that because like there's
almost no victory that's not tainted by
some other contextual element especially
starting with Miguel I mean Miguel is
becoming darker and darker as the series
goes on Robbie in the face and one thing
I hope that they start to address in
season 2 is I think it's interesting the
way the Cobra Kai mantras work into
these kids because like all of the Cobra
Kai team is kind of aggressive and kind
of bully-ish a little bit in their
determination to win at any and all
costs where they did you clearly have no
respect for their rivals you know it's
like even if Johnny is a better person
and perhaps a better teacher than his
sensei there's a lot of work for him to
do and I think this episode is kind of
showing him that I think like not only
does he have the stuff with Robbie to
think about but also the way Miguel goes
out there's like no I know what to do
I'm gonna do this the nastiest way
possible I think that's also something
that's getting to Johnny and I wonder
caught in between all these things now
how he's gonna evolve in season 2
because he's been like the most
fascinating nucleus of this show kind of
the whole time so yeah we had Internet
what were you saying I was talking about
you know how it's Turkish I am my
prediction for season 2 is first half
Johnnie will feel the pressure to work
with the original instructor because
he's the guy who met Nick over time or
at least that's what I think he meant a
cobra guy I don't know if he had like a
higher up and then Cobra Kai was passed
I I don't know
for all intents and purposes he was the
face of cool yeah so my impression is
he's gonna feel pressured and that he
has to work alongside with him because I
don't think he ever had that
confrontational moment with him where he
told him about how negatively influenced
he was by his master because he even has
that moment at the tournament he's
looking at the photo and he's looking at
him like did I become this guy this is
not who I wanted to become now is his
chance to face it so my prediction is
that guy it's gonna take over topic I
mmm Johnny is gonna work with Danny in
some fashion they're gonna have to buddy
up I think that would be cool and then
BAM two of them fight him at one time
yeah yeah there's no more reality no
more humor about aging guys living in
80s nostalgia it's not be considered a
season three it's gonna be full gun
chases explosions the whole nine it's
gonna be gnarly Hawks gonna have full
Sims the next time we see him it's gonna
be crazy
I feel like I got what was going on with
Miguel just from knowing how a young
male ego can be when you're in this
environment - there's a Cobra Kai
influence but also your hearts been
broken and you've kind of had this suck
it up mentality being bestowed on upon
you from Cobra Kai so he feels like he
was in the right for how to react to
Robbie but it's like it seems like
there's so much ego now within him but
it's all defense mechanism well yeah and
you've got the 180 his whole reputation
at school and his whole interactions
when most people must have gone through
when he beat up you know Kyler and those
dudes in the lunchroom and like now you
know he's probably got a lot going
toward his head yeah at the moment - you
know a lot of those stresses I felt like
some of the way he was portrayed in this
episode I was able to understand from
thinking about it seemed a little
jarring at times it was like well you're
like to the max - down [ __ ] man this
is just post breakup ego hurt feelings
flashing out that's happening cuz it
wasn't a hundred percent made clear it
seemed rather extreme you know so you
ever seen him arc and be more addressed
but the last time I saw him get
aggressive Robbie he was drunk he's not
drunk here maybe he's just hurt and he's
lashing out oh no he's still drunk
he's still drunk a couple days yeah has
not worn out that was his first beer
yeah it was nice for Sam and Aisha
maybe his Rene for them to make amends
happy about that that was one of the few
little nice things yeah I feel like
every kind of victory is tainted by
something except that one what was
fascinating was you know like as we were
doing the reaction that I said at one
point there's probably gonna be like a
sweep of like opportunity and Johnny's
not gonna want him to take it which is
exactly what happened except Miguel
didn't listen and took the opportunity
and it was an interesting flip for them
to have the victory but to see that
they're not really winners in the end
yeah I just feel like there has to be
something where Dani and Johnny have to
start you know working together in some
way especially for the sake of someone
like Robbie who's you know Johnny's kid
and he wants to make amends with him and
even Danny's encouraging them to get
along and make amends with each other I
thought that was a really nice scene
that that whole moment I mean like
whatever Johnny and Danny get in the
room together that sentiment never
really carries over yeah but when yeah
he gives him the talk about true balance
and being the bigger person and whatnot
I did really appreciate that moment for
sure I think because of that though they
have to change the direction of the show
just can't be competitiveness the entire
time yeah and even the last couple
episodes here we're opening that door
for them to start not like Abril buddies
but that kind of dynamic where they
don't like each other but they're
getting along in a way maybe it work for
something bigger than yeah and I can
imagine that leading to more interesting
conflicts you might have it that if
Johnny and Danny have to partner up
somehow you might have a rift between
Johnny and the Cobra Kai
who he's spent so much time shaping into
what they are now and like you know when
you do that with the impressionable
minds of young people they sometimes
will not come along with you if you
should change your tune and so yeah I
think this definitely sets up a lot of
good potential for the next season I
mean with this fun as these are to watch
combined with all the stuff we just got
I can't wait yeah yeah my one major
criticism that I have for this I feel
like there have been fight scenes in
here that have been grounded in some
kind of reality even when they're doing
karate there's been a sense of reality
as if they're really doing this but
fight scenes all at the tournament okay
no protective gear no one heard of the
amount of like Facebook yeah kicking the
face like a head on like a lot of the
moves I've never seen that at a
tournament when there were a couple that
were like flying care like the kinds of
kicks that you can't land softly
especially for like a kids tournament
yeah I was kind of shocked with it I
don't know I I don't ever really like it
in movies in general when the guys who
can do the flips and the crazy combos
like the real trained martial artists
that you brought on board to do these
fight scenes are doing crazy stuff but
then the actors who have been trained
for a few months to prep for this show
really just kick their asses you know
clearly those characters spent way too
much time practicing their gymnastics
another time practicing their direct
this is the choreography start tearing a
little too far off for me into realistic
at all
hey you can't do half these things in a
kid's tournament for karate the
choreography is very much stylized now
so there's some distracting out so it's
cool and then every once in a while
there's a cool kick or blow that lands
like when Robbie does the double kick
yeah but yeah that was a that's the
thing they can kind of pull me out at
the same time I'm like what I really
wanted the realistic karate you know
maybe in the end I probably do prefer
this over that I'll meet you halfway and
say let's get maybe like a couple of
pads or something you could probably
make them look badass though with like
the foot covers and gloves yeah you know
make it like MMA style or some but then
again that criticism I brought that's
for almost every show that explores this
territory that's not that's all of them
this is an exclusive to the Cobra Kai
YouTube channel it's kind of been a
thread through even in the first product
kid movie they're fighting without gear
yeah yeah well and throughout the show
that's one element that has kind of I
guess I've chalked up to the heightened
tone as like so much of the time kids in
his class are getting like decked in the
face yeah kicked in the face and I'm
like having a parent in this day and age
not like flip their [ __ ] about that
alright guys well we finished Cobra Kai
loved this show cannot wait for season 2
they really did love this show a hell of
a lot Susan - Kent coming soon or what
you guys didn't Cobra Kai what do you
guys think predictions for season 2 put
it down below and Asner come back oh
let's hope so hey you guys can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell and please do check us
on patreon fold my TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is a whole bunch of goodies
love to have you become a patron eject
today doo doo doo doo doo doo